foreign
I just want to go over the parts
where you're utilizing
a postural slash energetic
technology
to sink that she dropped the mind
we want you to be able to identify those
so for example exhaust Zen you you adopt
from the top part of your body that's
what you're doing you're not
trying to calm down you're not doing
mindfulness
you're aligning your physical
aspects
for an energetic
dropping of the Mind a sinking of the
chief
a generating of the lower taunted
okay do you understand what we're
talking about about now okay
so
you have it here and you should seek it
you shouldn't be here getting ready to
go you're here and you're gonna feel
and you're going to organize your body
for the perceptions slash experience
of the mind dropping
is you take you're supposed to be able
to do it in about three to five breaths
okay that's what's culturally given to
you to do it
you know it doesn't go take three
breaths then go
it's you have three breaths to do what I
just said do you understand
okay if you can't do it you can't do it
just start
it doesn't matter if it's three or fifty
okay but that's what you're trying to do
here
so when you go on with the technique
boom
you're trying to keep that as much as
possible
to the next part where you do it again
why because the ego tripartite mind is
this you can think of it as the standard
preset it's the the manufacturer preset
like you bought a smart watch and it
comes with a watch face only this one
after you change it to the one you want
it keeps going back to the
manufacturer's preset that's like your
ego tripartite mine so you generate
however you want to call it drop the
sink in the cheese drop in the mine
generating the lower tonden field and
you hold that
perception feeling into the next one
here it is
so that transition between if you pay
attention to my torso posture it's
exactly the same do you guys see that
but my base of support is different
okay
so when you came off here
you're you should feel the contact
points of the pace
almost
energizing each other
and that sinking dropping feeling is in
between them
okay then you hold it
and you move it
and you got it again
and again
you're all moving so here now it's
between your feet and then so the feet
have to press against each other that's
what I mean they're they're holding me
up
or more that sinking is pushing my feet
away from each other
all right come up here you have another
one and you should recognize this this
is your standing meditation right
got it so midfoot vector
right
save the cross Saint the cheese drop the
mind you're here when do you come out of
it you shouldn't come out of it so you
can do it
here wait
back
and then sink
draw and the feet will press out as the
center drops not here do you see I'm
front foot heavy you guys see that
a lot of times you can use that backflip
to tell you you're doing it wrong
it's why you lose your balance a lot
your heel is up that means your weight
is forward
sink
release and relax the heels just barely
up
okay
feel this part this is where it loses
you guys
and I've I've watched you you're kind of
always barely falling
do you know what I mean
understand this
as analogous to an arc
so the gravitational pull
right is pushing out
the bottom part
you don't want it to cave in the middle
get that energetic component going
okay got it all right let's get that far
and then I'll show you the remaining
ones okay
okay so we left off here
and so you have that sensation of that
dropping sinking chi in mind
and this is now moved it forms going hey
Dave see if you can keep that feeling
and do the next movement do the next
movement
and now follow that dropping sinking
line down
you guys see how I'm doing that I should
know what that feels like and where and
there and therefore I know where it is
and that's the line that I followed down
okay
then hey D come back up that line so
young on that line Dave Young on that
line cool and then guess what an
understanding meditation here
right and understanding
same standing drill we do all the time
you know
here so when do you leave
when it's down
come back
keep it
now come out of it
okay
your the speed of your form
is really
a question of how fast can I sync it and
how long up can I sync it okay
it's not a fancy match
it's an energetic practice
so
think I can move
boom I can lose it shakes up
I'm inside my my body mind sink
I personally like to as if I stay sunk
all the way to here here I'll give me
some time
and get that energetic drop going
and then I go on
take my time again
here I I'll go a little faster because I
can keep that sunk as I'm moving okay
try it again
okay so as I said you're not in a sword
fight
you're in this energetic ritual
this is a training tool
and all training paradigms are about the
application is stress for the purposes
of adaptation
so sooner or later it's going to do
something
that will probably break your ability to
do the drill
and then with pre-modern training
paradigms
they're also after Transcendence
so you're going to be challenged in
terms of what seems not possible to the
ego tripartite mind
okay so here everyone gets sinking
settling mine down I'm over myself you
imagine gravity working on my body but
she and mine is not my body
you that's the premise it's just it
works for you as a modern person
said all gravity that but you're coming
from a material point of view okay but
right away you see the drill goes hey if
you if you can sink and you understand
mine cheese not body
binder Chi is not body you should be
able to go up
you should be able to go up and still
sink so I am going up my body's going up
but I don't lose the sinking feeling
and then the next one very common to
combat
is
your Sinking Feeling should be down
perpendicular to the Earth
but now you have a Target
and the target will pull your mind
and as it pulls your mind why why will
it pull your mind because your ego
tripartite mind is functioning so the
desire to hit the target will pull your
mind and now let's just materially
represent the sinking mind sinking Chi
line
now you have a gravity here and you
start to tilt do you see well now you're
not sinking so it looks something like
this so you go here and
now you're not sinking you actually came
back up
so the drill is doing the stress
adaptation paradigm
sync come up come up without coming up
boom forward without going forward
see how it's paradoxical okay move
forward without moving forward boom here
your sword goes up what does usually
happen your mind Chi goes up
no sword goes up line stays centered
and now this
is hey you know where you're you drop
the chi mined at like a level 10 go to
level eight
push it down more you see the stress
adaptation model so you're coming around
home go to a
it drops more you see you guys get that
it drops more so you don't cut here in
Kitty at the ocean oh drop more
around now come back to 10. you see I
came back to ten then the same thing the
drill is going to do the same thing hey
you're down you're down go ahead and
come up come up without coming up come
up with still the sinking feeling
all right gather yourself
when you sink though spiritually
what happens
when the Mind drops
and then she drops and it's impossible
to distinguish
what's what because you only have the
perception and it's never separable from
reality my perception of reality is it
the cheese thinking is it my mind
dropping who gives a
I can't ever the same too you guys
understand that if I if I feel it
sinking my mind is the one that's
feeling it got it okay so when you're
here at this park
this is your classic she's in Thai
dropping my G drilling so hang out here
again
and then as you move
don't have rearward making you go
hereward it drops feeling drops
drops
start to drill again do something
drop down the line you felt and then
again stressor come up the line but
still sinking still sinking
regather yourself
stay in it moving
if you're doing this there's a few
things you won't see you won't be
blinking
you won't be holding your breath
you won't see tension you won't see
teeter-tottering
you won't see your heel up
you won't be bothering me
your eyes won't change your ears your
eyes are in this your mind and cheese in
this right so every time you see that
and you also put in there your sword tip
your sword tips not all wiggling around
with stuff okay all right let's try it
again